US President Donald Trump's Mideast
peace plan is meeting stiff resistance
in Cairo the Arab League rejected the
proposal saying it does not respect the
rights and expectations of the
Palestinian people Palestinian President
Mahmoud Abbas has cut all ties with
Israel and the United States including
Security Cooperation many Palestinians
have already been protesting across the
occupied territories and plan for sees a
small demilitarized Palestinian state in
exchange Israel would be allowed to hold
on to many of its settlements and annex
some of the land it currently occupies
we asked correspondent Tanya Kramer in
Jerusalem to tell us more about the
Palestinian decision well we're talking
here about security relations the
Palestinian leadership has already cut
off diplomatic ties with the Trump
administration in December 2017 that was
when President Trump recognized
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel but
they still kept some relations with us
security agencies and intelligence
services so they could be are cut off
now the other thing is the security
coordination with Israel that happens on
the ground between security agencies
Palestinian and Israeli agencies in the
occupied West Bank that is a very
controversial issue actually for a very
long time among the Palestinian public
there has been a lot of pressure always
on President Abbas to stop this kind of
security coordination so if he goes
through that this time this would be a
big headache for the Israeli security
establishment